Hey, everybody welcome or welcome back
to another Rawkus rendition of roll-on wherein
to wit the duly anointed pod knighted,
Sir Adam Scolnick and I dissect matters top of mind,
matters seminal and of great consequence
and matters perhaps specious, whimsical, and or vape it
depending upon your vantage point.
We also do a wee bit of show and tell,
and of course, answer your questions from our (indistinct).
Did a Scottish man write this copy for you?
I didn't realize I was-
I was feeling free with the pen
when I came up with this.
I like it, I didn't realize I was pod knight
but I appreciate it.
You could do the whole podcast in that accent.
How about that?
I challenge you.
(indistinct) lots of listeners, right?
(indistinct)
You know, I speak to dogs that way now.
So as I'm running by, if there's a dog,
I go, "Hello mate, how are you?"
And the dog owners love it.
This would fall under the specious aspect of things
to be disgusted at TMI my friend.
Listener questions, if you want your question answered,
leave us a voicemail at 4242354626
so lean back, lean in, smash that subscribe button
as the YouTube kids say, that is what they say right?
Is it.
(laughs) The only YouTube kids I watch
are 30 years old, Chad and JT.
Yeah, well, they're like 14 though.
Yes I love them.
All right, well, let's get into it.
I wanna kick things off with just a quick announcement,
"Voicing Change" is back in stock,
so for those of you who are new here
"Voicing Change" is my latest book.
It's a coffee table rendition of the podcast
featuring wizened excerpts and poignant essays
and glorious photography from some 50 of my favorite guests
over the last eight and a half years of doing this thing.
We are ready to ship globally direct to your coffee table
or your commode, depending upon how you enjoy literature.
I enjoy literature on my commode.
Plenty do, I'm not afraid to say.
We have signed copies available,
so learn more and snag your tome.
Visit richroll.com/vc
which is the only place you can get this book,
we're not making it available on Amazon or Barnes & Noble,
this is a self published thing.
So again, richroll.com/vc, Adam, what's up.
I like that you made that choice.
Well I get a lot of messages,
like how come I can't find it on Amazon?
So this is why we have circumvented-
I can't believe (indistinct) like that.
(laughing)
Yeah, it's because of a personal vendetta
that I have with Jeff Bezos.
No, yeah, it's Bezos.
I'm good, man, life, it hasn't changed,
still, mostly at home and was able to-
It has changed though.
What?
It has changed, because nothing is static,
the universe is expanding Adam.
It's expanding in front of my eyes.
As is your consciousness.
I'm not so sure about that.
Really?
Yeah, I don't wanna be-
Is your consciousness contracting?
It just depends on the night's sleep.
Like today I feel like my consciousness has expanded.
I didn't sleep so well last night.
So it's a narrowed.
Yeah, the wind it's been so crazy windy here
and for some reason, the wind keeps me awake at night.
It does to me too.
And full moon, I never sleep well,
so we're just past a full moon.
I never like the day before a full moon,
the full moon evening and then the following night,
every month it's a weird like lunar gravitational pull.
I don't know what it is
but I have restless nights every time.
If anybody out there knows anything about why that might be
I actually I'm getting Matthew Walker on the podcast.
We have him scheduled sometime in the next couple of weeks.
He's the guy who wrote "Why We Sleep",
he's like the leading sleep expert,
that's gonna be my first question for him.
Well, Chinese medicine like considers wind
in like well-being considers elements like that.
And I think (indistinct) medicine does as well,
if I'm not mistaken, so experts chime in.
I think your consciousness is expanded
based on that response.
Thank you but just based on
but how does my consciousness look?
'Cause that's what's really important.
(laughs) I think you're looking fabulous today.
Good.
I mean other than the wind, the weather has been great,
I'm enjoying the new studio,
I'm excited about all the pods that we've been producing-
Dude you're a hero going, right?
We had Raghunath which was great,
it was so fun talking to him, Steven Pressfield,
personal hero, Jedidiah Jenkins, all-
Amazing, what a great lineup so far just this year role.
Yeah and we've got exciting new people on the horizon.
Also been working on some compelling new top secret projects
that I'm not ready to discuss quite yet,
but that has me getting out of bed pretty pumped up lately.
I'm feeling fit, feeling grateful so (indistinct).
Yeah, how's your body's feeling?
What's going on with the back?
Back is feeling okay,
I've been getting some good work on it
from my man Lawrence (indistinct)
who's really been helping me out with my posture
and my pelvic placement all these like things
that he's been doing subtle changes in how I move and run,
that seems to be helping, so yeah, man, I feel good.
Nice.
Speaking of feeling good, we're one week out
from the Goggins four by four by 48 challenge,
so we gotta check in on where you're at
with that physically, mentally, emotionally
spiritually, consciously.
Okay, where should we start?
I don't know, you tell me?
Well, I'm spiritually dead, so let's not go there.
(laughing)
No, I'm just kidding, kidding folks.
I feel good.
Maybe that'll be good
for getting you through the challenge.
(laughs) Okay, so first of all, Nicholas Ramirez
has come in hot with some great coaching
in the last couple of weeks.
He snapped to it after the last podcast?
Here's the thing about podcasting
as you may be well aware, you don't always say what you want
it doesn't come out right all the time.
And then it's like out there and people listen to it.
I have a little experience with this.
That's what I'm saying.
Do you experience podcast regret the next day?
Not often, but it certainly has happened.
And now we're in such a hair-trigger world
that I feel more cautious than I ever felt before.
Not that like, I don't know what I would say
that would be that controversial.
Well, all I said in relationship to Nicholas
was that he wasn't really
doing a lot of personalized coaching
and mostly I was just getting stuff through the app
but that was okay 'cause I actually like that,
and so that's what I didn't say.
'Cause actually personal coaching
feels kind of intense for me
and I actually like kind of just doing my own thing,
give me a workout to do
and then I can make it work and do it.
And so I've actually really enjoyed it
and it has helped my fitness overall.
But then once he heard that, yes, he kind of he's like-
Thursday morning, the phone's ringing, what do you mean?
No, not so much that he was like, he felt bad
which I didn't want him to feel bad,
I mean, he's got a million things and it's great
just to have the team member workouts
but he's been tailored some stuff.
So it's kind of been a combination
of stuff you've suggested, he suggested
and David suggested to me.
So on, I guess it was a week ago
Sunday or Saturday or Sunday, I did my first simulation
which was three times every four hours.
He suggested instead of doing a two and two and two
or whatever to do three, four, five.
So I did that and that included the five mile at night
which was my first night run,
'cause I never really run at night.
I don't know the last time I had run at night
where I started out at night.
And, and so that was great,
that was a good little beginning,
and then just Friday, I did four, four, three, three.
He wanted me to do four, four, four, four,
but then David thought it'd be better
because he knows my foot situation just to do three threes,
four threes but I decided
to do a little bit of kind of a mix.
I did four, four, three, three, starting at noon,
no starting at eight in the morning or eight or nine
and then every roughly three to four hours,
so I did the last one at night and I felt strong.
That's great man, so how did that feel?
I felt really strong.
Like I felt like at my fastest miles
were the last run and I wasn't going fast
'cause I'm doing zone two but like I felt strong,
like I could have done another run.
So I feel like the first day I feel very prepared
for the first day like other than I'll have to grab sleep
but other than that, I feel like six fours
is not going to be extremely difficult for me
barring any sort of weird mishap where I step off a curb
and hurt myself.
So this kicks off Friday?
Friday at 8:00 p.m.
Friday at 8:00 p.m. so this podcast goes up Thursday,
so to literally go up, people will be consuming this
on the Eve of the launch.
And I will do some Instagram stories,
so David's gonna do every run,
he'll be doing something I'll be watching his
and then I'll do something either
before or after a run probably after,
is probably when I'll check in mostly
'cause I wanna be connected to him.
There are 500, David just posts about this,
there are 500 people who've already signed up
through his website from 45 countries.
I heard from someone from Iceland through Instagram
messaging just now who there's two people
in Iceland that are gonna do it, but 45 countries literally.
How many people total?
Just the 500 that we know of because they've messaged
through the app through the website
but really you're not supposed to post
about that you're gonna do it,
you're supposed to post about that you've done it.
So he wanted people to do it that way
but people have been doing it ahead of time
when she's embraced.
So it's a whole worldwide movement really
of people doing this I think is really cool.
It is very cool.
It's so wild how David has been able to just Marshall,
this massive following of people to get on board
with something challenging and hard like this, it's amazing.
And yeah, and he was talking about it,
the unifying aspect, how, if people just wanna focus
on getting better and doing something hard for themselves
and that it becomes a unifying thing
with people from all over the world,
different vantage points, viewpoints, backgrounds,
whatever political leanings can come together
just shows that we are capable of coming together,
which is cool.
And this isn't the name
of really a very challenging thing.
So the second day
I have no doubt will be extremely difficult,
I'm not like going in overconfident at all
but I've got some electrolytes now.
No, I was gonna ask you
if you've been practicing your nutrition and hydration.
I have, your sponsor sent me
about 150 packages of electrolytes.
Elements?
Elements, so they're either terrified
that I'm going to fall on my face at some point,
or just want me to try it.
So I use that during the first simulation,
I didn't hydrate very well,
I didn't have it planned out very well.
The second one, I had the element stuff
which really helped, I hydrated and ate much more mindfully
and it was working.
And I have a dozen Japanese sweet potatoes
those small ones, that I'm gonna cook ahead of time.
I'm gonna have a lot of avocados in the house.
Soak some dates too, those are good.
Yeah, dates, I can get dates, I can get dates.
That's great, man, no stomach problems?
You know, what's funny,
what's good about the Friday simulation,
it just so happened I woke up
with like a little bit of a weird digestive thing
and one of those headaches that's kind of like
those nine kind of almost food poisoning, headaches.
And I woke up with it and I went running
and the first two miles of the first run, I felt it.
And then I finally ran through it,
and then the second run, same thing
'cause I hadn't hydrated enough.
After the second run, I really made sure
I did two electrolyte 16 ounces
and then that kind of washed it out
and I felt great by the end.
Yeah, I mean, that's why one of many reasons
why doing the simulations are so important
because you're putting yourself in the position
that simulates what you're gonna feel like in that moment
and you're able to test things like hydration, et cetera.
The other thing that I thought that you said that was great
is that you began running and you didn't feel good
and you kept going and that shifted.
And I think that's a really important lesson
for anybody who's listening, who is dipping their toe
into the endurance world.
There's gonna be days and moments and times
whether it's in training or in a race
where you're not gonna feel good
or you're gonna start running
and you're gonna feel terrible and think, well,
I don't have it, I need to quit.
But if you just stay in it, you realize and you learn
that things change and shift, just 'cause you feel lousy
in one particular instance
doesn't mean that that's gonna persist.
Like you can kind of work through that
and you have these breakthroughs
when you do these simulation weekends and you realize,
oh yeah, I got through that, I ended up finishing that run
feeling better than when I started,
and that's very empowering in terms of providing you
with the confidence and the experience
to whether something like this.
Thank you, that's it, that's what I felt.
I felt like, okay, the headache's not great,
but it's not the worst headache I've ever had,
so I'm gonna do it and I'm gonna look at it.
And we slept horribly the night before,
the baby was really restless and so I felt like good,
I felt confident, like this is a good thing,
let's see if I can do it now,
so that's how the simulation started,
and it ended like a lot better.
The rough part's gonna be those like ones
in the middle of the night or in the early morning.
That's gonna be tough for me, it's gonna be tough.
I'm just gonna get he first night,
I'm gonna stay up to the midnight run,
I'm not gonna try to get any sleep until after midnight,
and then do the midnight run,
then get a little bit of sleep, get up for the four
get a little more sleep and then try to stay awake all day.
That's the plan.
Well, I've got a ride plan for Saturday,
so maybe on Saturday, I'll ride down
to your neck of the woods and try to track you down.
Hell yeah, that'd be amazing.
And I'll grab your phone
and do the Instagram thing.
That'd be amazing.
Yeah, speaking of riding, that's really been something
that I've been focusing on lately.
I've just formed this new ambassador relationship
with specialized bicycles which is really great.
And they've got me kitted out on this new Turbo Creo SL,
and I put gravel tires on that and I've been getting out
and riding on gravel for the first time.
I've never been a mountain biker,
I've always been a roadie, but there's so much gravel
and fire roads around where we live.
So gravel bikes are good for fire roads
and like those gravel road?
They're not meant for like super technical
sort of mountain biking
where you're like jumping over rocks and things like that.
The gravel bikes don't have like the shock absorption
and that kind of like geometry, but they're great
for just riding on dirt and loose gravel
and the fire roads basically like the wildfire roads around.
And that's been super fun
and kind of a learning curve for me
but it's opened up like a whole new world.
So I rode from my house like I took down Mulholland
all the way to and down Mandeville
and like into Brentwood and around-
From your house?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Super fun.
How long is that?
It was like a 50 mile ride, I did like a big loop.
That's fantastic.
But here's the thing, so the Turbo Creo SL is an e-bike,
it's got a motor in it.
(laughs) Is that the one you said?
Yeah, so I took that and what's been cool and interesting
and new is the experience of riding an e-bike
which is something I have no experience with
and never thought in a million years
that I would ever have an e-bike,
like I'm a fitness junkie,
I don't wanna motor in my bike, I'm gonna test myself.
You gotta be some kind of lame,
like put a motor on your bike-
Just say limo, you'll get canceled.
I don't know what the appropriate vernacular is anymore.
(laughs) Just kidding.
But I had two experiences.
One, I went up to Santa Barbara a couple months ago
to hang out with Dan Buettner
and he's got a bunch of e-bikes
and he's like, you gotta ride these are super fun.
And I was like, a e-bike really?
And we took them out and we had a blast,
went all over Santa Barbara up all these climbs, super fun
and then I had Bryan Fogel on the podcast who people know
as the filmmaker behind "Icarus".
So he's a sick cyclist, like incredibly fit,
he also made the "Dissident",
the Khashogghi doc that's out right now.
And he was the one who got me excited about this Turbo Creo.
He's like, "You got to get this bike,
it's the greatest thing."
I'm like I hate e bike, he's like, no, no, no,
it's so fun, you end up riding longer.
You ride more 'cause it's more fun
and it allows you to go places you wouldn't ordinarily go.
Like going up these fire roads that are crazy steep,
even if you just had a regular gravel bike
you might not ride up
and he said that he's like increased his riding,
like I dunno, 30% from what he used to do
because of this bike and he's able to go out longer.
So do use it like selectively?
Basically, I keep the motor on like the low,
it has like rungs of power.
So I keep it, I either turn it off
or I keep it on the lowest rung
and it just gives you a little bit of kick.
So you're still getting a workout,
it's not like you're not riding
but then when you hit some like 20% grade on a fire road
you can just cruise up it without wrecking yourself.
And so I'd been out riding quite a bit
and I'm able to get a good workout, but not destroy myself
so I'm exhausted all day and then wake up the next day
and do it again and it's been like really fun.
And again, it's something I never would've thought
this was just something that I would be into,
but I'm really enjoying it.
The only thing that I had to do
is I had to decouple my bike computer from Strava
'cause I don't want any of these rides.
It's like, I've got a motor assist,
like I can't have these stuff up on like Strava
where they have segments and all of that
(indistinct)
it's like totally cheating, so I'm not riding
and I'm like feeling guilty,
like when I'm riding by somebody or riding next to somebody
I'm like that guy's got a motor, like, how lame is that?
I'm actually having so much fun with the whole thing,
and I wanna thank Specialized,
like, I'm excited about this relationship
and I appreciate the gear (indistinct).
It's a heavy bike though,
you couldn't go up a hill without it.
But the weight specifically is of it,
but yeah, it's like 26 pounds.
I mean, it's heavy to lift,
yeah, it's definitely like a very heavy bike.
What's the charge on it?
I think you can charge it up in like six hours,
something like that.
And it also in one of the water bottle cages
you could put a secondary battery.
So you have actually have two batteries
like a backup battery
Does the crank not generate any sort of a charge?
No, I don't think so, no.
But the range is pretty good.
I mean, obviously it depends on the power mode
that you're on and how much pedaling you're doing
versus how much the motor is doing the work,
but it's got something like an 80 mile range.
So I've gone out, like I did a six hour ride the other day
maybe two weeks ago and still had plenty of power to go
when I was done.
Cool, that's fun,
Yeah, super fun.
So I've been doing that and also amping up
the strength training, which has been fun too.
There's a gym near my house,
one of those chain gyms and they moved all their equipment
into a parking garage and they have like,
they take your temperature when you go in
but it's essentially all outdoors
and with with masks and all the equipment is like spaced out
over like a very large lot
and I've been hitting that like a couple of times a week.
So that's been my thing a little bit less running,
I haven't been swimming very much.
I mean, the pools are tricky to get into right now.
And the ocean is cold.
Ocean is cold, yeah.
I was with my friend Drew the other day
and he's been out swimming and he just, with a wetsuit,
a sleeveless wetsuit it's like,
he said something like 55 or 54.
It was 55 on Saturday, but then it got really windy again.
One of our friends, watches had 51 earlier in the week.
I wasn't out that day, but it's been cold.
Yeah, I'm gonna wait until it's about maybe 59.
(indistinct)
My blood is thin these days, my friend.
Speaking of cold weather and fitness challenges,
I do wanna shout out my boy James Lawrence, the Iron Cowboy.
For those that don't know James has been on the podcast
a couple of times in the past
most notably for performing one of the greatest feats
in endurance history, in my opinion,
which is this crazy accomplishment where he did 50 Ironmans
in 50 states in 50 days, which to this day
I just still have a hard time wrapping my head around.
How do you literally traveling from state to state
and making sure that he completed an Ironman
in each of the 50 States, never missed a day,
got the whole thing done.
Did he like cross state boundaries on the
like the run leg so that he could start again?
No, I think each Ironman was completed
within the boundaries of a particular state.
They had an RV and a couple of vehicles,
I think he started in Hawaii, then he went to Alaska,
so obviously planes were involved.
And then I think he went to Washington and then Oregon
and worked his way down the West coast,
and then across the States doing it by RV.
And then I went to, he's from Utah,
his 50th was in his home state, obviously near his hometown,
I traveled and ran the final marathon with him.
I made a little video about it that's up on YouTube,
but I can link up to the show notes.
He came on the podcast before attacking this challenge,
and then I did a second podcast with him
at his house after he completed it.
And so the reason I'm shouting him out right now
is he's doubling down and today,
we're recording this on Monday,
today is the first day of his 100 challenge
where he's gonna attempt
to do a hundred consecutive Ironmans in a hundred days.
He's not traveling state to state,
he's doing it all around his home.
So that means a lot more Hills.
He's got a pool, I mean, it's snowing,
it was like 27 degrees in Utah straight
but there's an outdoor pool that's heated to 82 degrees.
He's sharing everything on Instagram stories,
he's got a bunch of kids
and a huge crew and lots of support
and they're all kind of chiming in on his Instagram.
So you can follow along on his Instagram stories,
it's pretty cool.
That's awesome.
Is @ironcowboyjames,
I think is his account on Instagram.
So if you're not already following this guy, you should be
and this is gonna be a very interesting drama,
that's gonna unfold over a hundred days.
I mean, it's basically a third of a year,
it's gonna take him to do this crazy thing.
I feel ashamed right now.
(laughing)
I know, but this guy guy's bred for this thing.
This is a guy who I might butcher the story,
but as a demonstration of his sort of perseverance
and ability to suffer when he was a kid,
there was some contest in his town,
I think he's from Canada originally.
It was like the carnival came to town,
and there was some contests who could ride the Ferris wheel
the longest without getting off.
And he, I can't remember how long he stayed on it,
but he just refused to get off it like he just won,
so this is a guy who does not quit and-
We gotta get him to the Huberman lab and find out
like what's going on in there.
So anyway, I've had some texts back and forth with him,
he's in good spirits and I'm excited
to watch this whole thing unfold.
And I was the first person prior to him
beginning the 50, 50, 50
to say I don't think this is possible.
Like I told it to him, I was like I don't,
just not because I didn't believe
that he wasn't mentally capable or physically capable
but there's so many variables with the travel
in between states and logistics
and numerable things that could go wrong
that he couldn't control.
And having done something similar.
I mean, I tried to do five and we ran
into all kinds of stuff that made it impossible
to get it done in five and he did 50
and met tons of obstacles,
but was able to overcome all of them and complete it
and I just think that that's an unbelievable feat
and here he is now trying to do a hundred.
So kudos cowboy hat off to the Iron Cowboy
and we'll be paying attention and following along.
And speaking of like persevering,
even when you don't think you can,
like, you don't feel good, I remember from your book
I believe it was the fourth Ironman
where you thought you were toast after the swim
you spent all that time in the shower or was it the,
was it after the bike?
Yeah, like after the bike on the fourth one.
(indistinct)
And you just decided, okay, I'll just walk
for a little bit, but you, for sure were done,
and yet you weren't,
and then this one, you actually hammered it.
Yeah, yeah.
And that goes to the point that I was making earlier,
like you just have to keep moving,
and these things shift and change.
And that fourth one, I mean, a lot of that had to do
with sleep deprivation and also heat.
And this is an interesting thing about James,
it's like, why is he doing this, like it's 27 degree,
why didn't he start this thing in like May
or later in the year where he doesn't have to deal with snow
and subfreezing temperatures?
But he answered this question the other day on Instagram,
he's like, I do better in the cold
and I don't do well in heat so (indistinct).
Yeah, running in cool air is much easier for me.
Yeah, but would you rather there's cool,
and then there's cold.
You know, like 27 degrees doing Ironman
is not you cool.
In my book, get me to Hawaii.
Exactly, yes.
Anyway, we love you, James,
good luck with this, good luck to you checking in.
So let's take a quick break and we'll be back,
we got a couple of big stories,
important stuff to talk about and we'll see you in a few.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But first I do wanna snag a quick moment
to talk about something I care a lot about
which is the importance of nutrition.
And the thing is most people I know
actually aspire to eat better,
to incorporate more whole plants fruits, vegetables,
seeds, beans and legumes into their daily regimen.
Sadly, however, without the proper tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
And so, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everyone to experience some version
of what I've experienced, we decided to tackle
and solve this very common problem.
And the solution we've devised, I'm proud to say,
is the Plantpower Meal Planner.
Our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of customizable,
super delicious easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery,
you get access to our team of amazing nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many many other amazing features.
To learn more and sign up, visit meals.rich roll.com,
and right now, for a limited time
we're offering $10 off an annual membership,
when you use the promo code, rrhealth@checkout.
This is life-changing stuff, literally for just $1.70 a week
price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com, promo code RRHealth
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, back to the pod.
All right and we're back.
We got two stories for the big story,
the first one, Adam, why don't you kick it off?
All right, well, I just wanted to just talk a little bit
about this hate crime spree
that's happening to the Asian American community
or Asian community across the United States.
And when it started,
I believe it started first in Oakland
where there was a bunch of elders,
just walking the streets and getting pushed over
from behind or beat up or just slurs hurled at them,
but a lot of it was violent.
Like people were getting pushed over,
people were getting to the hospital with getting stitches,
breaking bones, this was in Oakland.
They caught somebody there, but then in New York City
a lot of stuff was happening as well
Queens and in Manhattan,
it was just became this replication.
And then it happened in San Diego,
and then I was saying, it's nice around LA
at least, we've been spared it,
and then believe it was yesterday,
I'm looking at "The LA Times" story from the 26th
and the Buddhist temple in little Tokyo
which anybody in the LA area
knows immediately where that is, was vandalized
and they tried to burn it down.
Two wooden lantern stands were burned,
metallic lanterns were vandalized,
it's at the Higashi Honganji Buddhist Temple.
And I've seen it many, many times
as a beautiful landmark building and listen,
I just find it appalling first of all,
that old people can't walk the streets
without fear for their lives and it's reprehensible.
But it's not something that hasn't happened before,
we saw it after 9/11, with Indian American community
and people of Arab descent.
After Trump was elected hate crime sprees spiked
in those communities as well, and now it's happening
landing on the Asian American community
so much that Jeremy Lin the basketball player
was called the coronavirus on court during a G League game.
So crazy, so does this track
to the coronavirus or what is the genesis of it?
It started actually if you look back,
if you will really you could connect
to this more recent kind of rash of cases,
to right after lockdown,
it started to happen right after lockdown as well.
So there was like, I think a viral video
of a woman getting called racial slurs
on the subway in New York,
when it was really hit in New York City.
So it started then, and now it's just kind of this new rash
of cases has happened.
There are leaders in the community, Lisa Ling, CNN,
she's doing a lot of kind of highlighting these cases
on her Instagram, Andrew Yang spoke about it,
I mean, it's a major, major epidemic it's appalling
and just wanted to urge people.
Yeah, I mean, what is there to say about it?
Like, don't be an ass hole, like, what is wrong with people?
I don't understand it.
And I would suspect that if you drew the Venn diagram
between the people who deny the existence of coronavirus
and the perpetrators of this type of crime,
there's gonna be some overlap.
So does the coronavirus not exist?
Or is it the fault of Asian Americans
who are citizens of this country?
I mean, it's appalling, it's disgusting,
it's disappointing and disheartening that in 2021
we're having to contend with this kind of racial strife,
it's unbelievable.
It's hard to fathom.
It's like, look, every day you wake up
you have a choice to make in your life.
And the choice, you're taught
from the time you're a little kid.
I mean, sure, some children don't get taught,
not to push people over when they're little,
but like even if you had the worst upbringing ever
if you get to the point where you're 15, 16, 17
and you think it's a good idea to push over an old person
kind of trying to make it down the street,
I just don't know what to do with you.
And it's like, so there's the hate crime aspect
and there's this elder abuse aspect
and it's all rolled up into one.
And that's why it's so horrifying, I think,
that's why it's even more horrifying from behind too.
And so, like the cowardliness that's involved here
and this, we're better than this, but we're not.
So it's like the human being should be better than this,
but we're not always.
And so, this is all of our responsibility
to fix this problem and that is calling it out.
If you see it, call it out, defend people
who are getting abused.
There was one video in Queens where this guy
like shouldered through an older woman,
pushed her down and nobody did anything,
like he just kept walking down the street, it's like-
Yeah, honestly, like I don't know what to say
because I can't wrap my head around,
like what would motivate somebody to do that?
It's people that are angry and disenfranchised
and looking for somebody to blame
and they see a helpless person who's an easy target
and that becomes the locus of their rage
and it's inexcusable.
And we're seeing this,
in addition to this Asian hate crime spree,
we're seeing it, we saw it with the black surfers
in Southern California recently.
(indistinct)
And the same thing, a black surfer was hassled
and splashed and called racial epitaphs,
and nobody in the lineup came to his defense.
And so then there was this paddle out and-
Right, I saw that.
And that was good, that was well attended,
it was hundreds of people I think came down
to support the black community there.
And look, we are a melting pot,
we are fed from all sorts of different cultures.
Surfing's a perfect example, surfing is not a sport
that originated in the white community,
it only exists because there was a friendship tour
from Hawaii that came and demonstrated it up
and down the coast of California
and then it became endemic here.
So look, we rely on each other,
we need to keep our radar up and so obviously
your listeners, aren't this problem,
but I think it's incumbent upon all of us
to be ready to respond.
Yeah, well said.
I wanna move on to other issues that we gotta talk about.
The next thing is something that caught my eye
and I thought it was worth spending a few minutes on.
I was listening to Mark Marin's podcast
and last week he had two actors
from this new independent film called "Body Brokers",
You had Melissa Leo and Michael K. Williams,
I listened to both of those and then was so intrigued
that I went and watched this movie "Body Brokers",
and it really struck a nerve with me.
Less for the cinematic aspect of the film itself
and more for the issue that it's addressing.
Essentially, it's a movie about a recovering junkie
who was recruited to a rehab only to discover
that said rehab really isn't about helping people,
but it's actually a cover
for a multi-billion dollar fraud operation
that enlists addicts to recruit other addicts.
And this is something that is going on
in the treatment industry at large
and is an issue that I think is under discussed,
under addressed, and in need of being dealt with
in a large way.
And as somebody who's very interested in addiction,
somebody who's been in recovery
for many, many years and a product of treatment
and a treatment center, a very good one,
I'm well aware and I'm steeped
in kind of the recovery community here in Los Angeles
and in particular living, sort of near Malibu.
I'm also aware that Malibu has become
this kind of rehab Riviera
where there's just tons of mansions
that are now living facilities-
And they're usually McMansions.
Yeah, exactly.
And I knew that on some level,
this is like a money making real estate play
because you can lease these houses
they have like 10 bedrooms, and rather than rent them
to a family at X dollars, you can rent out each bedroom
for a crazy multiple on that.
So instead of cost, maybe $2,000 a bedroom
it goes for like $20,000 a bedroom.
And so these things become money making machines
and that's why you're seeing a proliferation of them.
So I knew that that was going on
and I knew that there's a lot of sort of shady
sober living houses and treatment centers
but what I didn't fully understand or appreciate
is the extent to which this has escalated
into a full-blown insurance scam
that is generating billions of dollars.
So essentially what happened
is that when the Affordable Healthcare Act
was signed in 2008, it required every healthcare provider
to cover substance abuse treatment,
which is on its face a good thing, right?
It's like we're trying to provide access to treatment
for people that otherwise wouldn't be able to afford it.
But since that bill was passed nearly 2000 sober livings
100 inpatient treatment centers, and 200 detox facilities
opened up in Southern California alone.
So like 35,000 beds that need to be filled every month
and almost 500,000 that need to be filled every year
which brings a profit of something like $12 billion annually
just to Southern California.
I think the market cap all total to something
like $42 billion in the United States, which is crazy.
And so basically what happens is,
and what the film illustrates
is how these sober living facilities and treatment centers
are basically-
They rely on brokers to (indistinct) beds.
They rely on these brokers
who go out into the world and find junkies
and then they're able to,
even if these people don't have insurance
they have like these umbrella policies
that they can get their name under
so that they can get the insurance money.
And then they get them in the centers,
and then every single aspect of that experience is monetized
from the pillows to the sheets to the urine tests,
like everything that goes into that gets billed
to the insurance company and a lot of these
not so above the board institutions like crazy over bill,
like $600 for a pillow or something like that.
And then the insurance company will say,
well we're not gonna pay 600 but we'll pay 200
or whatever for like a $20 pillow.
And these things just start,
they're like money laundering operations.
And then it becomes about making sure
that those beds are always filled,
so it's not about getting these people well
it's about keeping them sick and if they relapse
bringing them back in and then cutting the addicts
on the vig so that the people that are in attendance
in treatment are actually getting paid to go to rehab.
They get a kickback.
And then there's something about like the first urine test
has to be negative in order for them to bill properly.
So they want you to get high one last time
before you get in and I saw that in a couple of stories,
that was in the movie, but also Florida
that was documented in California, it's been documented,
Florida and California, like South Florida
and California are the two-
Right, the sort of most high profile transgression
took place a couple of years ago
with this guy called Christopher Bathum-
That story is (indistinct).
It's a crazy, crazy story for people
that are not familiar with it.
It ended up being adapted into a series on Amazon
called "Bad Therapists".
But basically this guy Bathum, became director
of a treatment center in Malibu called Seasons.
In 2010, he was pushed out
after a bunch of heinous sexual abuse charges
and he would do drugs with the inpatients.
And I think he ODed at one point.
He then opens up this other treatment facility
called Walking Miracles in Koreatown in 2011
I actually have a friend, Cliff Brodsky,
who was an investor in that-
In Walking Miracles?
Yeah, and ultimately Cliff who I've known
for many, many years ends up being one of the whistleblowers
on this whole thing, which is interesting.
And in any event, Walking Miracles goes bankrupt,
that's why Cliff started to come out
and kind of tell the world
how this guy was really operating.
But then Bathum opens up Community Recovery in 2012
as this luxury rehab chain,
I think it grew to something like 20 clinics across LA
all the way out to Joshua Tree.
He had something like $30 million in revenue in 2015
at a 30% profit margin.
And when Cliff and others started talking
about what this guy was actually doing
the FBI got involved, the LAPD got involved,
started investigating him for his sexual relations
and his drug use and-
Well he assaulted you, right?
(indistinct)
Yeah, I mean, this guy was a bad actor across the board.
And then in 2015, Hallel Aaron, who's also a guy
that I've been acquainted with over the years,
a journalist here in LA wrote a cover story for "LA Weekly"
that kind of went into the details
of what this guy was actually doing.
He was never a therapist, he was like a pool cleaner,
all the stuff that he was up to, and ultimately-
But he did have certification and hypnotherapy.
He did, he was a hypnotherapist.
He wasn't in recovery himself.
He's never been through recovery-
He didn't know anything about addiction,
treatment or anything.
And that highlights, one of the problems
is that a sober living house is different
than an inpatient drug treatment facility
in that you don't need to have a certification or something.
Right, and the kind of if there's a genius to all of this
what he figured out was that if you combine a detox facility
with a sober living facility
you're essentially running a treatment center
without calling it a treatment center
because treatment centers have to be registered
and licensed and all this sort of stuff.
So he was able to operate sort of "lawfully"
and then run all this money through this operation
to the tune of $176 million before the house of cards
just completely caved in on him
And then the victims of this insurance fraud
are the insurance companies, that's why these things persist
because there's no, even though (indistinct)
are getting, some are actually coming through these things
and somehow getting sober, but a lot of people are suffering
and there's I think there were seven
or I saw two different stats seven and then 17 people
who ended up ODing and dying
after going through his programs.
And so, yes, addicts will suffer through this
but no one believes the suffering of an addict really
when they're especially at the height of their addiction,
they're like you don't believe-
Yeah, because their trust has been so eroded.
So a couple of things, yes, the financial victims
and all of this are the insurance companies
but the addicts themselves are treated like chattel.
And there's no regard for their wellbeing or their recovery.
Yes, some of them do end up recovering,
but the vast majority of them just get cycled
through this system and are used like cash registers
to do like a churn and burn.
And six months sober people are hired to (indistinct).
And that was one of the things the movie did a good job at
which was Melissa Leo plays like a therapist,
and she seems well-intentioned in that regard.
But when the protagonist of the movie
who's played by Jack Kilmer
who does a really fine job with this,
he's acquainted with my boys Trapper and Tyler,
Jack, when he's basically saying I'm gonna leave
like he's gonna leave against medical advice
Melissa Leo's character just says,
well, I don't think that's a good idea, but okay.
And there's no, there's no plan
for any kind of long-term treatment protocol
to get him sober.
Like he doesn't end up getting a sponsor
or going to meetings, like there's nothing in place
to make sure that he stays sober
because that's not really part of what this is all about.
So ultimately, I won't spoil the movie, you can watch it,
it doesn't end well, but-
(laughs) You just spoiled it.
But well, I can say it's a dark movie in that regard.
Yeah it ends in the darkness.
And I forget the actress's name who plays his girlfriend
but she was unbelievable at embodying,
like what a young addict is like in that place
as somebody who's known, many of those types of people.
Yeah, she was good.
The other crazy thing is that
a lot of these treatment centers end up hiring the addicts
and alcoholics that "graduate" from these facilities.
So you're literally letting addicts run the insane asylum
and if addicts are anything they're incredibly crafty
and diligent and persistent at getting what they want.
And so if you have any of them
that are at all criminally inclined,
like this this is gonna go off the rails
which is exactly what happens in the movie.
Well that's what's so interesting about, not interesting,
but what makes this whole story so crazy
is that basically the mentality of the scheme
that perpetuates this fraud and is the same mentality,
it's a drug dealer mentality.
And anybody who's ever required the services
of a drug dealer knows that drug dealers cannot be trusted.
And yet some of these people who are building
literally have a dealer mentality
when it comes to getting people in treatment,
getting them out not giving a shit, what happens
just selling and making the money.
And then these addicts are kind of acolytes
of the drug dealer.
And don't you think there's like a parallel there?
Yeah, they become indoctrinated into this system
and essentially many of them are relatively unemployable
or they're felons or they've never had a real job.
And they get a taste of like, hey, we'll just do this,
and it's like low hanging fruit
and suddenly they're in this system, which is another aspect
of the film's narrative that I think is really potent.
And I think on top of that, well, first of all
to kind of wrap the story about Bathum,
I mean, he ultimately, gets indicted on 50 counts of fraud
grand theft, money laundering, sexual assault, rape,
he sentenced to, I think he was 20 years?
No, it was 52 years, 20 years just for the fraud
and then 30 years for the serial sexual assault,
'cause he was convicted of that, seven women,
so 52 years total.
He's in prison now.
But this is sort of the tip of the iceberg,
like this is still going on and that's what's disheartening.
And to your point earlier, there are addicts
that are coming out of these experiences
in these recovery houses and telling people
like look, this is what's going on but nobody's believing.
They're like, yeah whatever,
like you're not a trustworthy source.
No one believed those women.
I think that allows this kind of thing
to continue to perpetuate.
So I'm really glad that this movie exists
because it's shining a spotlight on this.
And like I said, at the outset of this
like I care deeply about recovery and it's so disheartening
that it's been hijacked and abused to such an extent.
I had a life-changing treatment experience,
there are good treatment centers out there,
there are good people, well-intentioned people
who are providing really good care.
You paid for that, right?
Yeah, I did, I did.
But I'm saying that still exists now,
but I think anybody who's kind of looking at this
needs to be more cautious than you used to have to be
about what you're getting involved in.
So maybe you can explain,
because one of the closing kind of thoughts in this movie
is it's not about like basically going
to the bells and whistles kind of real world
house version of a rehab center.
And it's more about 12-Step is free
and 12-Step has this incredible track record.
So maybe you can explain the difference
between those two and why 12-Step for you,
you think is still kind of the undisputed champion
in terms of its effectiveness and what it does?
Well, 12-Step is very effective.
Like it works if you work it, not everybody works it
and not everybody gets sober.
And when you've been in recovery
for any extended period of time,
you end up going to a lot of funerals
and you see a lot of people go out and not come back.
So it's heartbreaking as much as it is life affirming.
It's real life and sobriety is hard and it's slow
and it's not linear.
And 12-Step is not perfect in that regard.
If you look at the statistics,
the truth of the matter is most people who try to get sober
don't achieve long-term sobriety, they just don't
and that's just a fact.
But 12-Step is free, it's open to all comers,
it's decentralized, there's no money laundering going on,
there's no boss, nobody's in control.
And that sets it apart from the treatment
that the sort of corporate conglomerate
treatment infrastructure, which is about making money.
And when there's so much profit to be had
you're sowing the seeds for ultimately corruption to exist.
I think, my experience was about indoctrination
into the 12-Steps and that was part and parcel
of my treatment experience
was learning what that was all about
and then creating a long-term care plan for when I got out
so that I could maintain what I had,
the process that I had begun during that a hundred day stay.
It's not about, massage and Reiki and going four wheeling,
like some of these are like luxury spa experiences.
And like, I'm not against self care, but don't be confused,
that's not treatment, treatment is rolling up your sleeves.
And look, there in the movie, you see there's a therapist
and like, that's great.
But also that should also be understood to sit outside of
and be considered distinct from actually the process
of like working the 12-Steps and working with a sponsor
and helping newcomers and the like.
One of the horrible, horrible outtakes
of the Bathum story was he would rape
or otherwise sexually assault women
and then they'd end up in a survivors kind of support group
within the sober living house and he was running it.
Like unbelievable.
Yeah, so that's how bad it was.
So what you're saying is going to a safe space
helped kind of removing yourself from the real world
as it existed, 'cause it was so twisted for you
and you were kind of twisted up and it helped
to put you in a place where you could receive
some of this information and then linking it
to a 12-Step program was like the bridge you needed
to be able to work it.
Yeah, I mean, there was something very valuable
for me to be able to opt out of my life
and go someplace and focus entirely on getting well,
but it was not a luxury experience.
Like in the movie, he just kind of waltzes in
and they give him a bed.
Like when I walked in, they strip search you
they go through your luggage, they make sure
'cause people are trying to sneak stuff in.
They're not that kind, like they threw me in a room
and they basically wouldn't talk to me for two days
until I like dried out.
And it was pretty intense and hardcore
there was not a lot of coddling,
we weren't going out on field trips or anything like that.
Like it was really structured
and it was more like a mental institution
and it was a great facility,
but it was kinda like being in a hospital ward or dorm,
it wasn't like being in a mansion with an ocean view,
I can tell you that.
Yeah, and then the idea like,
that's what's so heartbreaking about this story
is that they are advertising safe spaces to try to get well,
and then it's anything but safe, actually you're the prey,
it's like twisted.
I didn't even know anything about this.
So I hope that this movie will prompt more conversations
like this and greater oversight because a lot of this
stems from the fact that there is very little oversight
when it comes to sober living houses and detox facilities
and there's just too much money to be made.
So we need regulatory oversight
over how these insurance funds are dispensed
to make sure that people who are in need of treatment
and detox, can still access that.
I mean, I think sober living facilities when done right
are incredibly beneficial.
Like the idea is you detox, then you have inpatient
and then you have outpatient and for a lot of people
they need a transition to real life.
And the sober living house provides that soft landing
so they can live with other recovering addicts
and alcoholics while they go out into the world
and try to get jobs, but they're still accountable
and there are still certain rules.
So to the extent that we can craft and create
some regulatory oversight
over how these things are conducted
to make sure that people are safe
and that they're fulfilling their intention
is what I think we all want.
Yeah, I mean, I think from what I read
that was the reason that there's so little regulation
around sober living houses, at least at the time
was because they didn't wanna be a lot of red tape
because the more red tape, the more likely
that someone in the neighborhood would find out
there was a sober living house now in their neighborhood.
Yes and they're not in my backyard.
It would be a NB thing, and so there are good intentions
that created this situation like Obamacare,
trying to get mental health and drug addiction,
recovery mandatory for these insurers,
that's a great intention.
And it can be considered a preexisting condition.
Right, and then sober living houses
the intention was to make a discreet
so that they could exist.
But the tragic thing is that you have addicts
who cycle through this and become,
not only did they not get well they become calcified
around recovery because their experience was so bad.
And they realize like what's really going on there,
and they become hardened to the process of recovery at all,
and then lives are lost, lots of lives are lost.
Thanks for bringing it to my attention,
I can't believe I missed this entire story
over the last several years.
It's crazy, right?
Yeah.
All right, let's move on.
What do we got?
We're gonna do a little show and tell now.
Yeah, show and tell.
Well, do you wanna start
with the newest podcaster on the block?
He's a small timer in the game,
you might've heard of him though.
The Boss and Obama getting together on Spotify.
So listen, Barack, I know you were president for two terms
and you're dashing and handsome and the like,
but I don't know what makes you think
you can host a podcast, this is a skill, my friend,
it takes years.
You might have a degree in hypnotherapy
but you're not a podcaster.
(laughing)
So I had to go to (indistinct) to get this job.
I haven't listened to this podcast yet,
but this was big news, Spotify made a big splash
with this Bruce Springsteen, Barack Obama podcast episode.
Is it intended as just one episode
or is Obama gonna now like interview people
like what's going on?
I don't know if "Renegades" is this shingle
where they're gonna just pair two people together
and it'll become something-
Like an iconic class, remember that show, iconic class
in IFC where they get to
like they had Eddie Vedder and Laird Hamilton
spend the day together.
Right, right, right.
Or is this "Renegades",
is Barack Obama gonna just interview other people?
It's hard to know, I listened to the first episode
on the way here and I mean, Barack Obama is very good.
I'm sorry, he's such a good interviewer,
but I'm struck by two things.
One is Barack Obama is a great podcast host
and he is the host he's interviewing Bruce.
And it unfolds over the course of like,
I don't know how many episodes, maybe a half a dozen.
And the first one is about being outsiders,
growing up as an outsider.
And it's not like Bruce Springsteen,
hasn't told his life story before,
he's told it over the course of many record albums.
I went to the river tour where he just talked about,
like he just performed that album and talked about his life.
He did a Broadway show and now he's in this,
but every time he talks about his life story
it does feel fresh.
I mean, he is very gifted in that category
and the two it is great to hear them together.
And I found myself suspending all those kinds of thoughts
about what this means for podcasting
and just kind of enjoying these two people.
But so it's good, it's good content.
Spotify is like, if you couple this
with what Joe Rogan's deal was
with the Bill Simmons Ringer deal,
it's incredible what they're doing
They've really stepped up.
I mean, they have made big plays
to try to own this corner of the Internet
and they're putting great stuff out there,
so hands off to them.
It's an interesting move on behalf of Spotify,
they're recognizing that owning a significant part
of podcasting market share is in their interest
for a number of reasons not the least of which is
when you look at how these tech platforms
grow and become de rigueur
it's about monopolizing your time.
Like the idea, the sort of parameter
is how long can we keep you on our platform?
And when Spotify has listeners listening to music
they have to pay royalties out to the record labels.
But when they have a podcast on,
if they're listening to Joe Rogan for three hours
they're on Spotify for three hours listening to ads
but they don't have to pay.
I mean, they paid Joe upfront
but they don't have to pay royalties out.
So it's in their interest to move towards podcasting
and away from music
as a way of capturing people's attention.
And they've got this crazy war chest
that they can marshal to get people
like Bruce Springsteen and Barack Obama on their platform.
Are they profitable yet?
I don't know what the numbers are, but yeah,
they're running it like a Hollywood Studio.
I mean Dawn Ostroff is running podcasting for Spotify,
and she's been magnificent at recruiting top talent
and developing, what their...
It's basically like Netflix for podcasting.
Right, so crazy.
Good on them.
You had some other insights into this,
you're reading something right before we went on,
how does this help or hurt kind of podcasting going forward?
What was your takeaway on that?
Yeah, that's interesting,
there's a "New York Times" article today
by a guy called Ben Sisario,
the title of the piece is called "Podcasting Is Booming,
Will Hollywood Help or Hurt Its Future?"
I have a variety of thoughts on this.
I mean, first of all, there's a conversation to be had
that I'm not that interested in,
which is if a podcast is on Spotify
is it even a podcast because it's four walls there,
it's not an RSS feed.
And podcasting technically
is when you can disperse an audio file
and make it publicly available across the Internet.
I don't think that that's an important distinction,
I think we're moving towards this subscription future
where everybody's gonna be putting their stuff
like whether it's sub stack and newsletters
like everybody is segmenting content
behind a variety of subscription paywalls right now.
So it seems like
this is just the natural evolution of things.
Podcasting, I wasn't the first to start a podcast,
but I've been in it longer than most,
now, eight and a half years almost
and it's changed dramatically.
It used to be a hobbyist sort of pursuits,
and something that a lot of comedians were doing.
But now it's being monetized significantly
across the board with the bigger shows
and with that influx of money,
you're gonna see the corporatization of it
and the growth of things like Spotify.
So it's not surprising, I still believe,
I wouldn't say it's a meritocracy,
I think if you're starting a podcast right now
it's very difficult to get audience share
because there's so much content out there
and not just in podcasting, but across the board.
So if you're just looking at trying to grab attention share
in the attention economy, when there's Netflix and Hulu
and HBO, all the streaming platforms
and then everything that's going on with audio right now
including all the apps that are available
what are you creating that's gonna be compelling enough
to draw people away from whatever it is
that they're paying attention to
and pay attention to your thing?
I think is incredibly difficult right now
and we've benefited from being early on
and getting a little bit of a land grab
that we've been able to hang onto.
God forbid, if we tried to start this thing now,
I think it would have been incredibly difficult.
But I do believe that being said,
that quality rises to the top over the long haul.
It can, it doesn't always work that way.
Right, but if you're good and it's not
about getting millions of people to listen to,
it's like who are your hundred true fans
or the thousand people that are interested
in what you're doing and podcasting is still,
there's no barrier to entry anybody can do it.
And if you pick a particular niche that you find compelling
there are other people out in the world
that probably will agree with that and you can-
One thing that helped you is you had three,
kind of three-pronged niche.
You were kind of like, you have the sobriety,
you have the plant-based and you have the endurance power,
and putting those three things together,
it was kind of a calling card for you early on.
I guess, I mean, I never really thought of it that way.
I mean, that's probably true
but I just followed my curiosity.
And now if you were just gonna start a podcast
and just say I'm gonna talk to interesting people,
like good luck.
Even movie stars have tried to do that and failed,
people who already have big following.
So it's not easy and just because you have name recognition
doesn't mean that you're actually good at this thing.
It's a skill, even though Obama is knocking out of the park
with his first go-
Yeah, great first guest.
I think, you know, like if I go back
and listen to my early podcast, I'm sure I'll cringe.
I would never do that, but it's like you grow
and change with it.
But I think with this influx of money
you're gonna see higher production quality,
higher production value.
And you're getting scripted series,
we see a lot of the true crime stuff
and now these new narrative storytelling
which is old radio, it's old times radio
coming back packaged with movie stars and big budgets.
And the idea is that this becomes IP
that you can develop into miniseries, TV shows and movies
and the like, like WeCrashed, the Wondery series
is being developed as a movie right now,
a lot of that is going on right now.
So there is a lot of attention being paid to this,
but at the same time, like the way that I look at it
is I'm just gonna keep doing my thing,
I'll try to get better at it.
And I believe that long form, interesting conversations
with compelling people is never gonna go out of style.
Yeah, I think it's interesting the kind of family rivalry
that's budding between Michelle and Barack,
Michelle's book kills it, then Barack comes out,
his book kills it.
She has a great Spotify podcast is doing great,
he comes out with Bruce Springsteen, like six part series,
(laughs) they're fueling each other.
It's funny, isn't it?
It's great (laughs).
I wonder what those conversations are like at home,
I'm sure they're very supportive of each other.
There's definitely some like poking though.
Like, oh yeah, how many books did you sell today?
(laughing)
We're gonna have to get the real story
from Sasha and Malia at some stage.
But I will say like,
as part of this "New York Times", article this idea
that as podcasting becomes big business
there's unease that the diversity of voices
in our earbuds never a strong suit of the industry
could be put at risk too.
That may be true,
but like what are we supposed to do about it?
Like, are we supposed to put protective measures?
To what?
I don't know, that's what I'm asking.
To make sure you have the right amount of percentage
of people that are (indistinct)?
Right, which brings up the broader discussion
about content moderation and podcasting
which I don't know how you could possibly do that.
I think you have to just let
like you said, I think anybody can get into it.
Anybody can buy a couple of Shure microphones
and get into it.
You can do it on your iPhone and upload with Anchor,
you don't even need Shure microphones,
Shure microphones are nice though, they're not cheap.
No, but there were, they 500 bucks.
Something like that.
Yeah, I mean, just go on TikTok and start dancing,
you'll build a huge following
and you can just create a podcast out of that.
All right, man, what do we got next?
I saw a movie this week
called "Diving Deep:The Life And Times Of Mike deGruy"
Mike deGruy, I mean, it was made by his wife, Mimi,
Mike died tragically, I don't wanna spoil it,
but he was an incredible underwater cinematographer
and nature host.
And you may never have heard of him,
but he was also a submarine pilot, a technical diver,
you've his footage.
If you've seen "Blue Planet", you've seen Mike's work,
If you saw the "Titanic" documentary
that James Cameron produced about finding the real Titanic
he was the DP on that.
If you've seen the footage of the orcas
playing with the sea lions on the beach, hunting them
he was the first guy to shoot that.
So he is a giant in that space,
he's on the level of, kind of in the Jock Cousteau,
Sylvia Earle category in terms of an incredible,
all around scientific mind and cinematographer
and kind of blurring those lines.
I mean, he is one of the truly great people in that space.
And I didn't even know his story until I watched this movie
and it became, I think Mimi started to look at footage
from his years in the editing room,
nine months after he passed away
and started to put together this movie.
This is a great snapshot of who Mike was, where he grew up
how he got into it, a shark attack that he survived,
his becoming a submarine pilot,
his going to the Gulf of Mexico after deep water horizon,
that disaster happened and how he got so angry
when the dispersants were dropped to sink all that oil
and what dispersants do post oil spill to the ecosystem
in general and how that kind of angered him
and mobilized him.
And she interviews a lot of luminaries from that space,
including James Cameron, several times.
I've never seen James Cameron, who you all know
"Avatar", "Titanic" director.
I've never seen him so disarmed in an interview.
Usually he's pretty kind of uptight and reserved
and he is just like really wide open in this interview
and there are reasons for that
and you'll see why, but you credit Mimi for that.
And just to respect these watermen
that people don't hear about
and how much he cared about sharks
and how much he cared about the marine ecosystem
and how curious he was and how excellent he was
at all these.
To become a great underwater cinematographer is one thing,
to become a great technical diver is another thing,
to become a submarine pilot is another thing,
to do all of that while raising a family
and do it all in one lifetime
is absolutely it's unfathomable to me, it's incredible.
Well, I'll have to check it out, I haven't watched it yet,
I'm super interested in that.
"Diving Deep", we'll put a link in the show notes to that,
"The Life and Times of Mike deGruy"?
deGruy.
He's from Mobile, Alabama.
So his wife, Mimi is the one who directed the movie?
Yap, she made it, yeah, cool.
So technically this is show and tell.
So I thought I don't have
any big specific show and tell thing, but I did wanna say
that I get like so many books in the mail,
and often I get multiple copies of the same book
'cause they don't know that they send it to me
or maybe the author sends it to me
and then the publisher sends it to me.
And generally these are books for podcast guests
or potential podcast guests.
And I've had a habit of either donating them to libraries
or to goodwill, but I thought I would do a giveaway.
So I just grabbed a couple that were in my office right now.
I have multiple copies of Adam Grant's "Think Again",
I've got a second copy of Jedidiah Jenkins
"Like Streams to the Ocean".
I got two copies of this amazing book
that I'm just starting
called "Exercised" by Daniel Lieberman,
who's a Harvard professor.
He was one of the pioneers of the barefoot running movement,
he's part of Born to Run
and I'm trying to get him on the podcast.
This guy's got amazing stories and he's super cool.
There's a petroglyph on the cover.
There is, yeah.
It's all about like human ancestry and movements.
Is that a petroglyph treadmill?
Yeah, it is, I think.
(indistinct)
It's a peloton.
Is that the Ancient Greek peloton?
The point is Adam, stay on track here.
I'm Sorry.
I got a bunch of books that I wanna give away.
And plus, I brought out a sketch
that Brian O'Hara did for me on YouTube,
you can see this.
How cool is that?
So Brian, my artist friend, Brian, who I've spoken about
on the podcast before, he's the one who created our logo
and he's got a bunch of artwork here in the new studio.
He has a very interesting lens on the world,
he sees words backwards, he's not dyslexic,
but he has a different relationship
to his like visual cortex than most people.
So his art is in this kind of reverse hieroglyph style
that makes it almost look like Arabic
or something like that.
And he kind of encrypts his artwork with positive messaging.
And this is just a piece that he like did really quick
and ripped it out of his sketchbook and gave it to me.
I've got a bunch of these, so I thought it would be cool
to give this away on the podcast.
I'm not even sure what this says-
How are you gonna give it away?
I think it says peace and plants.
Does it?
Read this.
Let's see, well, there's definitely peace.
Yeah, you see peace.
I think it says peace and plants.
And as you can see for people who are just listening
it's just torn out of a spiral notebooks,
it's not framed or anything like that.
But I believe in Brian's talent
and I think one day he's gonna be a massive success
as an artist so this could be a valuable thing
to hang out on to.
So how do I do this?
I don't know.
I mean, maybe just subscribe to the YouTube channel
and leave a comment below the video
with why you think that you should get this book
or this piece of art and we'll pick somebody.
Perfect.
How about that?
I love it.
Cool, so that's my big show and tell for today.
Good show and tell.
All right, you wanna talk
about Lawrence Ferlinghetti, right?
I do wanna talk about Lawrence Ferlinghetti
and this is kind of a teachable moment
and maybe a hat tip to a legendary man in publishing
and in poetry, he died, you may have heard or read
at 101 years old recently,
I guess it was February 23rd, the obituary.
So either that day or the night before.
Lawrence Ferlinghetti started a bookstore in 1953
called City Lights in San Francisco,
it's in North beach, kind of in the transition zone
between Chinatown and North Beach.
Dwight Garner the literary critic of the "New York Times"
called it almost certainly the best bookstore
in the United States.
For me, it is, like it's kind of a landmark.
It's a historic landmark.
A landmark, a Holy temple.
It's an icon of a time.
Yes, a Holy temple of mad men and people
who are looking for truth in this world.
And basically he started the bookstore
within a couple of years and it was just all paperbacks
and at a time when paperbacks
weren't really being sold too much.
So he started this paperback bookstore,
and because of that, it was like he, things were cheap
and he acquired a bunch of people
coming to San Francisco and they showed up
at his doorstep and a lot of them were poets.
And then within a couple of years
he launched a press to start publishing these people.
One of them was Alan Ginsburg and his story turns
and the story of the beat literary movement
turns when he publishes "Howl",
which I'm holding it up here-
Ferlinghett publishes "Howl"?
Yeah, Ferlinghetti publishes it-
And City Lights has like a banner?
That's right, and he published it in,
I think it was '59, '57, '56, publishes at 1956,
it's the first thing he published is Alan Ginsburg's "Howl".
'Cause he performed it in City Lights
and a 56 page book that became a sensation.
And partly because everyone heard about it
and they came in to buy it and the police,
San Francisco police had an undercover cop come in
and I guess he was under 18 or they were following someone
and they sold, the book seller sold it to someone under 18
and it's sexually explicit.
And it talks about homosexuality and all sorts of things,
and it's 56 pages, especially the poem "Howl",
which is as you know, one of the great poems
because what it did was it broke verse
from something stodgy, like poems of the old age
and became much more stream of consciousness style.
And anyway, the bookseller was arrested,
Ferlinghetti the publisher of the book was arrested
in the owner of the store was arrested
and it became a landmark First Amendment case
where basically it was tried, is this obscene literature
or is it not?
And is it protected by the First Amendment?
And it turned out it was, they had a good lawyer.
Was Kunstler the lawyer on that?
I forget, you know, there's a James Franco movie
that talks about it, I didn't watch it.
Something tells me William Kunstler was the lawyer.
Yeah, they got like a heavyweight lawyer
that came in and argued it, even though it wasn't-
Kunstler is the guy with the lawn, he did Chicago 7.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So it was a municipal case
but it had national implications.
And luckily there was a federal court case
that they use as a precedent
and this kind of reinforced that precedent
that if there is social value,
it can't be considered obscene.
And so that's what the argument was
that everyone was innocent of charges
and this poem became a sensation
and basically fueled this beat movement
which included Jack Kerouac, Gary Snyder,
Jack Kerouac on the road
and all of those Gary Snyder, Neil Cassidy,
and Ferlinghetti himself
who published "Coney Island of the Mind"
which is one of the most successful poetry books in history
one million copies in print.
And so the legend was built right around that era.
And what I think is what's one of the things
he used to say is when life gets too awful
look for the lyric escape.
That's something Ferlinghetti says, and that can be writing,
it could be painting, it can be sex, making love,
it could be running, swimming, diving,
reach for a piece of mind, that's the lyric escape.
And to me, City Lights was a lyric escape,
every time I entered that building.
And so they gave us great literature
but they also kind of bridged,
they were open to Zen Buddhism,
they were open to kind of an expansion of the mind.
It wasn't just about reading a great book,
it was a reading, a great book that allowed you
to look for that expansion of your own self.
It kind of was a precursor to a lot of the yoga stuff
that kind of came right in the '60s
and the yoga movement and the personal development movement.
So it's one of those really pivotal literary movements
in our culture and Ferlinghetti was a foundation.
Right, and I don't know that we mentioned this
but we're bringing it up because he just passed away.
Yeah, no, I did mention.
Oh you did?
Yeah, he passed away down at 101 years old.
Right, I mean, City Lights, the vortex
of the counterculture movement of the '60s
it birthed the beat poet generation, Neil Cassidy,
all of that and if you haven't visited City Lights,
it's still there or like-
It closed down during the pandemic,
so it just closed down and then it raised
a bunch of money through one of those we have GoFundMe.
And so now it has $400,000 to hopefully reopen
but they have not committed to reopening.
Yeah, yeah, they can't let that fail.
They can't let it fail now.
Just like you can't let the strand fail in New York.
As a Stanford student, did you go into the city?
Was that on your radar City Lights?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, I remember the first time that I went in there,
knowing full well, the legacy and the history
that's baked into that.
And I was, as a young person,
fascinated with that period of time,
I remember reading Tom Wolfe's,
"The Electric Kool-Aid Acid Test"
and it just blew my mind and reading on the road
and all of that.
So I love all that stuff and it is interesting
how what is the the long-term legacy of that
and how it's getting played out right now.
Like everything from Lululemon to this now,
swap in how we're thinking about free speech, right?
Like free speech being the Vanguard
of the progressive liberals during this period of time
when people are getting arrested for selling copies
of "Howl" to underage people
to now that being a mirror image of what it once was.
Right, well, so like exactly, to your point,
it was the overlords of the old culture
of like the 1950s,
the stodgy kind of religious institutional culture
that was saying, no you can't say this,
this is the wrong thing to say
and basically arresting people for publishing a book
because it had the wrong words in it.
And now we're making punk rock non-conformance stars
at a mediocre minds when progressives are doing that,
by saying you can't say this.
Right now progressives are the ones
who are policing speech and it's strange and disorienting
to see that happening.
And part of that is rooted in progressive progress,
and part of it is perhaps a bridge too far
in terms of-
I think it starts with again, good intentions.
We're not condoning hate speech here,
and people, if you allow free speech to the maximum level
hate speech has to be protected too.
Like there's a reason the ACLU have filed cases
to support KKK marches.
The idea is that you keep it open
so that the marginalized have a space to speak.
But that is by nature going to allow
everyone to have a space to speak.
But you know, we're not condoning hate speech at all
but we need to have the big picture in mind always
when we're talking about freedom of speech.
A good beat poet title for the current age,
Jason was saying this before we went on
please stick to the approved words.
That would be the great poet title of the current age.
Right, 'cause that's like a very provocative,
punk rockish title to have in this moment, right?
Right, right, right.
And that doesn't mean that we don't understand
where it's coming from or don't have empathy
to people who felt marginalized
and want to make things better
but you can't control making things better
by saying what you can say,
and when you can say it and how you can say it.
'Cause if that was true, we wouldn't have old people
getting pushed over on the streets, everything would be cool
but it's not cool.
All right, let's do some listener questions.
Okay, listener questions let's hear from Josh
from Raleigh, North Carolina.
Hey Adam, hey rich.
This is Josh from Raleigh, North Carolina calling.
My question is an aspirational riff off
of the conversation that Rich recently had with Alexi Pappas
about the importance of surrounding oneself
with high vibration people.
So my question for both of you is
if you could have a road trip, a pilgrimage
some type of a adventure with three people living or dead
who would they be?
For me, it would be Rich Roll, Ram Doss and Father Richard,
sorry, Adam, much love namaste.
(laughs) Namaste Josh.
I can't come?
Can I be the driver?
That's very generous, I'm flattered.
I wouldn't pick me.
You're bemused, you wouldn't pick yourself?
(laughs) No.
You have to go, it's a road trip.
Who do you got?
Me?
Yeah.
I divided it up into the living and dead,
and the living I'm picking Barack Obama
'cause he's my favorite podcaster.
(laughs) You're fired.
Thich Nhat Hanh and Elizabeth Gilbert
'cause she's pretty chatty and she'd be fun.
Because when you're going on a road trip
there's lots of things to consider.
Like how often is this person gonna need to pull over
and go to the bathroom,
what are their dietary restrictions like?
Like are you gonna be able to do the long hang
as you go away across (indistinct)?
So you have Thich Nhat Hanh old timer, who's seen it all,
and Barack Obama, they could talk,
I think you'd have a lot of great insights
and Elizabeth Gilbert,
all very well-read people, I'd learn a lot.
I just like to sit in the backseat
and listen to Barack and Liz Gilbert get chatty.
Which would be good.
And Thich Nhat Hanh just like-
Chime in, he'd just drop a little Pearl
every once in a while.
Thich Nhat Hanh was as you may or may not know
he was a Vietnamese, not refugees,
Vietnamese monk, who ended up
having like early mindfulness meditation influence.
And he and Martin Luther King Jr. were very tight.
So my undead is Bruce Lee, 'cause he's a cool movie star,
John Coltrane, 'cause he's him,
and Anne Frank in then Liz Gilbert role.
Did you intentionally make these sort of appropriately
diverse also you have for each the living and the undead
you have an African-American and Asian and a woman?
(laughing)
I'm trying to be, you know what I thought about it
but it probably would be John Coltrane,
Bob Marley and somebody else if I had to pick.
But in this sense, since we're on live on the air here,
not live, but on the air
I figured I have so many things I'm interested in,
I'm not even into martial arts,
but I saw the Bruce Lee documentary recently
and it was either him or Napoleon and I went with him.
Napoleon would be cool.
He might be a pain in the ass though, too.
He'd wanna drive.
(laughs) He'd be in control the whole time
But we'd have to like strap blocks on his feet
so he could reach the pedals.
This is tough, I get asked this question a lot.
Like, who would you have dinner with.
I always stumble, I can never come up with anything
that interesting.
I mean, I just riffed off this, off the top of my head,
but for the living, I had Michael Stipe,
David Attenborough and Richard Branson
or possibly Haruki Murakami, that would be cool.
but I don't know.
Michael Stipe because he's leasing out
your favorite all time band?
All time.
Yeah, he's a must.
But I could go with Barack, Liz Gilbert,
these are all cool people.
Like it's also about the curation, right?
Yeah, that's the point.
Because you're not gonna be talking the whole time
or listening the whole time.
Like, are these people gonna get along with each other?
You need to have, first of all,
you need to have men and women
because you have to have a nice balance,
yes, and will they get along was a big thing,
that's why I think my living car is pretty rock solid,
I think that goes to me.
But the dead, you just don't know how John Coltrane
and Ann Frank are gonna get along, I think they'll be fine.
But if you have Liz Gilbert or you have like, Brene Brown
like they get to the heart of things quickly.
Yes, but maybe almost too quickly.
Maybe.
(laughing)
When you're dealing with 3000 miles ahead of you.
I don't feel like they would run out of things
to talk about though.
No, definitely not.
Who's your undead?
The undead, I got Marcus Aurelius
because what is it like to be the most powerful man
in the world and be a philosopher King?
And be played by Russell Crowe?
No, Russell Crowe didn't play Marcus Aurelius,
Marcus Aurelius was played by Rich, what's his name?
I'm blanking.
Oh, that's right.
He just passed away.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Richard Harris.
Richard Harris, exactly.
JC Jesus Christ, I mean, why not?
Let's get to the bottom of this, right?
I had Jesus on my list.
I crossed it out for Anne Frank.
It's a cope out though,
it's like Abraham Lincoln and Jesus Christ.
But like are you gonna not pick him,
if you can pick anybody?
And let's get to the root of this.
He's pretty famous.
And while we're at it, Bill W. why not?
Bill Withers?
Bill W. from the Secret Society,
the co-founder of the rooms.
I don't know him.
You don't?
Wow, it has been kept anonymous
at the level of press radio and film.
He's like one of the co-founders of AA.
Bill Wilson.
But I don't know,
like that's not the most diverse list either.
No, I don't think there's a right answer.
I feel maybe one of the reasons why I struggle
with this a little bit is that I get to do this every week
on the podcast.
Like the podcast is my version of going on a road trip
with somebody I wanna talk to.
Right, and if you listen to your podcast,
you're getting that.
It's almost like the Barack Obama, Bruce Springsteen
is half of the car.
Come at me, Barack, come at me.
It's an open seat, I'll kick Adam out of here right away.
Barack wants to come and step in and roll on, you're fired.
I'm outta here?
Yeah, he's shown his chops,
he can handle himself behind a microphone,
who knew, there's a job opening.
What about the boss?
I know it might be tricky.
It could be good, I don't know.
I don't see Bruce coming over here every week.
If Barack wants to come here every other week, I will.
Yeah, he's gonna get a pat down and point doom,
he's gonna rise Ducati here.
Podcasting is a meritocracy, I will have to give way,
I will give way.
All right, let's move on.
All right, this is another interesting question,
we don't get every day from Tara on Long Beach, California.
Hi, this is Tara I'm from Long Beach California.
So my question is I'm a family physician
who works full time, I have twin three year olds
and I am trying to dabble in ultra running.
My wife is supportive of my running
but in a way that can be frustrating
and difficult for our relationship.
So my question is how do I best balance these three things
that I have going on without disrupting the balance
of my relationships as well, specifically with longer runs
on the weekends and time away from family?
What is a good way to address these issues
and have everyone's needs met?
Thanks guys, bye.
This is a great question, I think this is relatable
for anybody who gets involved in endurance sports.
The term Ironman widow exists for a reason,
because these pursuits can often end
in cataclysmic relationship results,
if not handled appropriately so-
I figured you are the perfect person to ask this question.
Well, it's not easy.
I mean, this is the first thing I would say
is you're set up for failure right out of the gate
because this is a very difficult hat trick to accomplish.
And I think to launch into this
the first thing to bear in mind is you can't excel
at all of these things every single day.
Like, there's this idea of how am I gonna balance
all of these things so that I'm giving them
an appropriate amount of attention every single day.
And I think that's the wrong way to think about it
because you can't do that.
You can't be at your best as a physician, as a partner
as a parent, and as an athlete all the time,
like it's just not rigged that way.
So let go of that fantasy out of the gate
and try to configure a schedule and a structure
that allows you to kind of toggle between these pursuits,
understanding that on certain days
your priority is gonna be in one of these buckets
or two of these buckets, but not all of these buckets.
So that over the course of a month or a week
they're all getting an adequate amount of attention
but not all on the same day or at the same time.
So structure and scheduling super important.
I think that you should craft that schedule in cooperation
and partnership with your wife
so that your wife is part of organizing
what these days are gonna look like
that your wife is participating, in the allocation
of your time and energy and to come to that conversation,
trying or endeavoring to the best of your ability
to structure your training at periods of time
that don't compromise the goals that your wife has
or the parenting needs that you both mutually share.
So that might mean that your runs
have to be super early in the morning before anybody's awake
or late at night when everybody's asleep.
And I understand that you have a full-time job,
you're not a professional ultra runner, though,
nobody's paying you to do that,
this is something you choose to do
but you've got to make the choice of how you apply that
in a way that's not disruptive to your family,
you already know that.
And that means finding those windows of opportunity
that don't put your wife's schedule at peril
and create this tension in the relationship.
The other thing is you don't wanna ever set yourself
up to be overtrained or overly fatigued,
you've got to be able to show up a hundred percent
for your kids and for your wife when you're not training
and you're not working.
So that doesn't become an additional drag
on top of the hour spent when you're not at home.
And I think what's been helpful to me
in doing this is twofold.
First anticipate your wife's needs
and your kids' needs in advance,
so that you're planning for that,
and you're not like showing up,
oh you didn't get the groceries
'cause you had to go running or something like that.
These are the things that like are small things
in isolation, but they add up
and they can really derail a relationship.
So being ahead of the curve in terms of understanding
and anticipating what your wife is gonna need
and fulfilling those needs before perhaps she's even aware
that she needs them filled.
So that way you're demonstrating through your behavior
repetitive behavior, that you're conscious
of the fact that you're also running
is perhaps taking you away from the relationship
more than she would like but you're showing up
in ways that are telling her like you're here, right.
Even when you're not there, you're actually there,
and then when you are there to be a hundred percent.
Like when I was trained for Ultraman at my peak,
I've told this story before, but I come back
from like a 30 mile run or a six hour bike ride
and I'd walk in the house like just wasted.
And Julie would like hand me a baby
and be like your turn bye, I'm gonna go do my thing.
And I couldn't be like, I need a nap or I gotta like shower,
it's like, no, you gotta be on point, it's your turn.
And by respecting that and making sure
that I was present when those moments arose,
that's how we were able to kind of keep everything
moving and on track.
If I was just like, no I can't
or sorry I gotta train right now,
like that's not gonna work.
Were there times where she pushed back
against, like super long?
I mean, I was lucky because I have her very supportive.
She's all about you finding like-
Right, and that doesn't mean that it wasn't hard
because we're talking about a ton of time.
And also, we were going through some financial stuff,
it was like a very difficult period.
And I credit Julie tremendously
for really being an incredible support
in a way that I think most partners wouldn't
and can't be expected to, honestly.
So it's understandable,
like what you're gonna go run for...
Like we have twin baby, like, what are you doing?
Like you gotta be here.
So that's why I think anticipating your partner's needs
and the needs of your children is so important.
I also think that you have to choose your moments.
Like I said, at the outset, it's impossible to excel
at all of these things every single day,
and if you attempt this you're gonna fail
in all the categories.
You're not gonna be able to train like a pro,
So don't try to, and there's gonna be days
where maybe you have some big run on your calendar
and this is really important to you
but something went haywire at home and the kids need you
and you gotta be like, what are my priorities?
Like I gotta show up for my kids,
I gotta show up for my wife.
Like what is most important in the grand scheme of things?
Is it really worth derailing your relationship
for ultra running?
Like ultra running is something you can do your whole life
if you do it responsibly and so that doesn't mean
that your needs shouldn't be met either.
It's important If this is bringing you happiness
and fulfillment that you should have the freedom
and the license to like do the things that you enjoy doing
which is why communication is so important.
And if this is important to you,
it's incumbent upon you to communicate the importance of it
to your wife, so that she really understands.
Like she really understand why is this important to you?
Why are you doing this?
And the more that you can have
that channel of communication open with your wife,
I think you'll be in a better place to engender the empathy
and support that you're looking for.
But that's a two-way street,
you gotta give it in return as well.
You can't expect her to support you
unless you're supporting her in kind.
So what is your wife's ultra running?
Like, what is it that she would like to be doing?
And how can you go out of your way to make sure
that you're supportive to her in that regard
in the way that you would like to be supported?
It's great advice, I can't offer anything
to relate to this discussion other than,
'cause I'm not doing 30 miles-
But you have a baby and you're trying to do
this Goggins thing and you've got a show at home,
so how's that going?
I had to talk her into the Goggins thing.
She was not really feeling the Goggins thing.
(laughing)
Well, 'cause for her, she's like with the baby
almost all the time and I have my work,
which at least allows me even if I'm in the same apartment,
I'm in a psychic space, that is my own.
And she's not really permitted to psychic space
that is her own too often.
And so when I run training off and I'll take the baby out
with me in a stroller run
Right, that was the other thing I had
on my list of things to respond to,
like get the twin baby carriage thing,
is that what's it's called?
I haven't had babies in a while, what do you call them?
Strollers.
Yeah, strollers, (laughs).
It's been awhile, but it's still called strollers.
And she lives in Long Beach.
There's like those paths along the ocean,
where you can like push a stroller and-
Pretty soon they can ride bikes alongside you or whatever.
So I did have to talk her into that and it just took that.
I would explain to her why it was important to me
the best I could, even though I couldn't really explain
to you why it's important to me, but she understood that,
she never didn't want me to do it.
And it doesn't really show up as much in the running
'cause for me, most of my runs are a little over an hour
sometimes less, sometimes a little over an hour.
And if I wanna do a long one for me,
it's like a 10 mile run usually,
so that's like, it's not like a 30 mile run.
But swimming, at least doing the dives in Malibu
that has become a lot less frequent
than it used to be for me.
I try to get us out there once a week
but that includes taking everybody out
getting a beach tent set up, doing the whole thing,
otherwise-
As somebody who participated in that with you,
I can affirm that that is a languishing affair.
That goes on for hours unnecessarily.
I'm like, are we gonna swim and get this done?
What are we doing?
We're looking for our octopus T-shirt.
I'm like I'm out for a workout,
and you're looking for octopus.
Yes, that's right, we're getting in touch,
with our lyric escape.
Yeah, I'm like, no wonder.
She's like, what are you doing?
Get back here.
She comes out with us, so she's only been able to...
She went one time, she doesn't like 55 degree water,
so for her it's like if the visit is good
and it's warmish she's down.
And so we have made it possible for her
to go with the group and then I did my own thing after,
we've done that once but it does take,
like, I can't expect her to go sit on the beach
when the wind is howling
and it's getting sandblasted with the baby
while I go on a little swim.
So that is not happening as often as it used to
but she loves the beach also,
so she likes being out there.
So it's really about the communication aspect is important.
And you do have to kinda supplement,
especially knowing that I have four by four coming up,
basically after four by four,
she prefers kind of workouts with this trainer, from our gym
that we don't wanna go to 'cause of the pandemic.
And so we've been having him help us sometimes
and after the four by four 48,
and we're gonna prioritize more of those workouts
that she can do and then I'll do...
And so we're just doing that.
So that's kind of the thing she wants to do to,
how am I supporting her in kind, that's the next step?
So my running, I probably do little less mileage every month
and build in this other strength aspect,
and that's just how it's gonna have to be
'cause he can't do it all.
Next question.
Sorry, I made that about me, Tara.
You're in it right now, you got a baby.
I'm in it.
(indistinct) something hard, I feel you Tara.
All right, Emily from Minneapolis.
Hi, Rich and Adam.
This is Emily calling from Minneapolis, Minnesota.
I was just calling today
because I've been listening for years
and almost two years over and about 98% vegan,
so you could say I am drinking the Kool-Aid.
But the reason for my call is where are you both
consuming information at this point?
I'm curious what kind of podcasts you might be listening to
and also media and books and things like this
where you're getting that inspiration from.
Thanks so much.
Adam.
Yes.
You wanna take a crack?
She wanted to hear from both of us.
Oh, you want me to go first again?
Go ahead.
Okay, (laughs).
Probably 'cause my answer is gonna be
so disappointing so go ahead.
Come on.
Right now I'm reading James McBride's "Good Lord Bird"
which is about basically it's a historical fiction.
It's all about the John Brown abolitionists
who was this, kind of had an army of abolitionists
and they went and they wreaked havoc
on all sorts of slave owners in Missouri.
So he was in Kansas and they would run across the border
and just kill slavers and deliver God's justice.
And it's really hilarious,
it's actually kind of an offbeat hilarious take
on this real thing that happened.
James McBride, author of "Color of Water",
which won, I think it won National Book Award as well
or Pulitzer or something.
And then I didn't read that, but that was an memoir
about his mother, "Kill Him and Leave"
was the first McBride book that I read,
and that's about James Brown.
It's remarkable, I found it in some bookstore,
not many people have read it,
it's like a 200 page book and it's a sensational,
and this book is magnificent.
So I'm reading that
and I'm listening to "Save the Cat! Writes a Novel",
that's part of my it's my audio book right now,
part of my deep dive into the cat.
"Save the Cat!" is the screenwriting thing?
Right, and so this novelist kind of took it
and spun it, it's under that banner, but it's for novelists.
And she takes the same lessons and spins it
and kind of uses fiction.
And it's helped me just kind of like think,
'cause I'm between drafts on a novel that I've been writing
and I'm just kind of listening to it
and see if I can...
I mean an after two drafts,
I'm looking at like 10 draft kinda plan,
and so I'm listening to it now.
And then the podcast I listened to
aside from the "Rich Roll" Podcast, which I do listen to,
I listen to-
Barack might have to wait.
Well, yeah, that's true, I am listening-
Trying to hold onto that seat.
(laughs), I love listening to the "Rich Roll" Podcast,
I listen to, every morning, Pardon the Interruption,
this shouty sports podcast, and occasionally the Daily
and Revisionist History is irregular for me as well.
You know "Good Lord Bird" is a show starring Ethan Hawke.
I knew that, I've been wanting to read the book for ages,
then it became a show and I thought,
no, I'm reading the book first.
Yeah, I love Ethan Hawke.
He's fabulous.
We talked about his Ted talk didn't we?
Yeah, we did.
I still wanna get them on the podcast.
I just listened to him speaking of podcasts,
I've listened to an interview that Ethan did with,
I think it was either on the watch or the big picture,
like those those ringer TV movie podcasts, it was great.
Like I love listening to that guy talk
and he was talking about "Good Lord Bird"
and how much he loved the book
and how is this passion of his to play this character,
even though he thought he was too young to do it.
Like he thought it should be like Jeff Bridges
or somebody like that who is older.
But apparently I haven't watched the show yet
but it's been very well received.
Yeah. I mean, and well, the story is told
through the the eyes of an eight year old or 12 year old boy
something like a young boy slave who John Brown liberates
kind of against his will and mistakes him for a girl.
And so then he goes around dressed as a girl,
which saves his life, but he's like liberated
against his will goes with John Brown.
And John Brown is prone to all sorts of like crazy sermons,
like you can't eat unless he's done two hour prayer,
or something.
Right, he's all crazy fire and brimstone.
Like he's over the top, like all the time.
I said at the outset
that my answer might be a little disappointing.
I mean, here's the thing,
so much of my information diet is dictated by the podcast,
like who's the guest who's coming up.
Typically there's a book
or a bunch of podcasts interviews with that person
a deep dive into their life that involves 30 tabs
open on my browser.
So I immersed myself in the world of the upcoming guest
and try to inhabit that in the most method way
that I possibly can.
And that consumes most of my time
in terms of news my kind of go-to for news
is generally Twitter.
Like I follow tons of journalists and I follow journalists
of different mindsets and worldviews.
So I keep things mixed up in my feed in that way,
and so rather than open up the "New York Times"
or the "L.A. Times"
but I tend to consume my news through Twitter.
Don't know how many people still do that?
I do a lot of that too,
I get to a lot of links, but it ends up being-
And then I can read different takes on the same story
or different perspectives on what's going on.
In general, curiosity leads the way for me
and that's really what the podcast is about.
In terms of podcasts that I consume and listen to,
people are always surprised to hear this
but I don't listen to a lot of podcasts
that are in the vein of what I do.
Like there's a handful of other people
that are kind of would be considered
kind of similar to this show.
And unless I have a guest that I'm researching
who's on one of those shows, I typically don't do that,
'cause it sort of feels like this is what I do,
and that feels like homework as opposed to enjoyment for me.
So I end up listening to podcasts
that pique my interest in other areas.
Like I also, I love everything Malcolm does,
so I listened to "Revisionist History"
and his other very shows broken record.
I love conversations about movies and television,
so I listened to the big picture on the watch.
I do subscribe to the "Daily" I don't listen to all of them,
I kind of pick and choose with that.
I still, old school I still love Marc Maron,
the "WTF" podcast.
I've been enjoying Mike Birbiglia's podcast,
"Working It Out", which is fun,
have you ever listened to his?
No.
It's pretty cool, like, he'll bring on,
most of his guests are comics but he brings them on
and he has kind of a series of questions
that he asks all of them.
But the premise is really I'm working on this material
and let me like try it out on you and give me feed back,
and then they're like, I'm working on this,
and then they're like, so it's like a note session.
That's great.
Which gives you a glimmer, like a glimpse
into the creative process
and also this is a very important thing
for anybody who's trying to do anything creative.
Like how you give and receive feedback and notes
is really important.
Like who you choose to bring into that circle is important,
how you ask the question and how you receive the response
and how the person provides the response.
Like there are people who are really good at giving feedback
and doing it in a conscious way that's constructive
versus destructive or just negative.
And I think there's an art to that,
and when you can be in a receiving mode
and set your ego aside
and actually hear what the person is saying
and not be reactive and kind of embrace it
even if they're like, I don't like this
I think you completely lost the thread with this,
and you're like, oh, that's, can you be curious
and interested in why that person feels that way,
I think is fun and helpful.
And I think Mike is really good at that himself
and he's so fun and engaging to listen to, so I like that.
I listened to Pivot with Scott Galloway
and Kara Swisher for business.
I love Brian Koppelman's, "The Moments",
which is all about conversations with people.
Like what is your inflection moment in your career,
so the focus of that.
Just for fun, I love the "Rewatchables" when Bill Simmons,
like talks about old movies, that you love to go back to.
I love Rob Bell's podcast,
I like Pete Holmes, "You Made It Weird".
Like I'm always mixing up my podcasting like kind of lineup
but those are just some that I've been listening to lately.
Love it.
And I watch a lot of docs, I watched the-
You see everything.
No, I don't see everything,
but I try to see as much as possible.
I watched the first half
of the Billie Eilish documentary last night
which is fantastic.
Really?
Is that in Netflix?
Apple, Apple+, yeah.
What else is on your radar for movies right now?
I dunno, it's weird.
Like the Golden Globes were last night
and I didn't watch it, but I was kinda scrolling
through Twitter and looking at all the people that won.
And I was amazed at how few of the movies
or shows that I've actually seen.
Yeah, well, it's one of those years
where you're not going to the movies, you know?
I know, I know lots of good movies to be streamed at home
in the coming weeks.
All right, stay tuned listeners.
That's it, yeah, I think we did it are we done?
We rocked it.
I think we're done.
We're gonna land this plane.
(howling)
Awesome, man, thank you, how do you feel?
I feel good, I like this one.
I think I'll listen to it.
You gonna do?
Do you go back and listen to roll ons?
No, I don't.
(laughing)
No, hell are you saying?
I maybe once or twice, I'm trying to get better.
You've been doing this eight and a half years.
Yeah, but I can't go back and listen to old shows,
I don't do that, I never do that.
I can't just 'cause I can't, I can't.
I can't bear my own voice, no.
Can't bear to hear yourself, I'm with you.
But what you can do is you can follow Adam on the socials
at Adamscholnick@richroll on all the places.
I might do a clubhouse soon.
Are you gonna do a clubhouse?
Well, I listened to my friend Neil Strauss,
did a conversation with Jared Leto on clubhouse
the other night and I thought it was great.
It was super fun and people got to ask Jared questions
and I was like, this is cool,
will do something there, I don't know anyone.
Let me know.
Clubhouse.
At "Rich Roll" for that-
I don't know.
I don't know what I would do there.
I just thought I had a good experience listening and-
How many people were in the clubhouse?
I mean, it maxed out, I think they max out at 5,000
and then there's like spillover rooms.
So it was look, he's like a huge movie star,
so it was like everybody wanted to hear what he had to say,
but it was fun.
All right, if you wanna have your question considered
for a future roll on episode again
leave us a message on our voicemail, 424235 4626.
Pick up a copy of "Voicing Change" at richroll.com /VC.
Check out the show notes to see links
to everything we talked about today
on the episode page at richroll.com.
Don't forget to subscribe to the show on YouTube, Apple,
Spotify, all the places.
We got clips channel on YouTube if you dig the short stuff
including the answers to all the questions we asked
we're uploading those there too.
So you can find that at "Rich Roll" podcast clips
you just search it on YouTube
and it's linked up in the show notes and all that stuff.
That's it.
Done.
I wanna thank everybody who helped put on today's show,
Jason Camiolo for audio engineering production, show notes
interstitial music and matters sundry and unlisted.
Jack of all trades behind the scenes, Blake Curtis,
for his video, wizardry filming and editing all of these,
it's no small task.
Jessica Miranda for whipping up the graphics,
we've got Allie Rogers on deck today for portraits,
what's up Allie?
Georgia Whaley for copywriting,
DK our man for advertiser relationships
and theme music as always by Tyler Trapper.
And Harry appreciate you guys, thanks for the love.
I don't take your attention for granted
and see you back here in a couple of days
with another episode and back with Adam in two weeks.
I'll be here.
To tell us about the four by four by 48,
You might have to wheel me in, but I'll be here.
And just remember when you're out there
and you're hurting, that the Iron Cowboy
is doing an Ironman (indistinct) okay?
(laughs), Damn you Iron Cowboy.
All right, peace.